une zone de confinement dédié aux cas
critiques flambant neuf
trois chambres peuvent accueillir entre
3 et cette passion dans le contexte
actuel de risque de pandémie le service
de réanimation du plateau technique du
chum a préparé cet espace singulier
on est dans une zone en fait où il ya un
traitement d'air particulier dont claire
c'est un flux à pression négative
il y a donc toutes les mesures sont
prises pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
dissémination du virus et que la zone
soit pleinement confirmé sa mue
infectiologues service de réanimation
sont concernés au premier chef pour une
prise en charge optimale
une procédure a bien été instaurée
depuis quelques semaines en cas de
suspicion
il ya des tenues adaptées en stock pour
les équipes médicales
en revanche les résultats de diagnostic
dépendent des laboratoires parisiens et
dans la préparation du personnel il faut
encore patienter avant de pouvoir mettre
en place une technique de diagnostic il
y à des tests locaux à faire il ya du
personnel a formé il ya des circuits à
tester avant de dire avec certitude on
est capable de faire le diagnostic donc
ça c'est en cours et donc voilà on sera
on sera pleinement opérationnel la
semaine prochaine depuis le début de la
crise ces spécialistes sont en contact
permanent avec leurs collègues
infectiologues de l'hexagone dans un
réseau de coordination appelé le cored
cette maladie provoque une détresse
respiratoire elle ressemble aux
symptômes du virus de la grippe qui fait
de nombreuses victimes chaque année
il n'y a aucun affolement ça c'est
important de le dire
et finalement on est face à une maladie
qu'on ne connaît pas encore très bien
mais qui ressemble en tout cas beaucoup
à ce qu'on connaît déjà avec la grippe
c'est à dire une maladie qu'il faut
prendre en compte notamment chez les
personnes les plus fragilisées il faut
s'en protéger avec les avec les mesures
d'hygiène mais pas d'affolement pas de
panique
si les premiers cas en chine ont été
très virulent et provoque encore de
grandes inquiétudes
on peut porter la maladie sans symptômes
et guérir du coronavirus